hi everyone
uh thanks so much for joining today um
my name is adam resnick i'm from the
children's hospital philadelphia
um and it's been a really a great
session today
following up on previous session i had
the privilege of uh co-moderating uh
this session with dr storm will join us
shortly um and we'd like to start with
uh
a video from uh ethan daniels uh one of
our really gorgeous warriors
hi everyone i'm rally kittythen i'm 15
years old and just started high school
i'd like to share a little bit of my
cancer journey with you it all started
in the spring of 2017 when i noticed a
hard lump
pop up on the top of my head since it
didn't hurt and i didn't do anything to
injure myself
my mom decided to take me to the
pediatrician
after seeing many specialists and having
many tests and scans
we still needed answers well
we finally got those answers it was 12
33 pm on a monday
i was eating mac and cheese from a green
bowl in the kitchen and my friend
logan and i were watching youtube and
that's when my mom got a phone call she
answered the phone and immediately went
outside
i know my mom and i could tell
that she was stressed and i even saw
that she was crying
after a while on the phone she finally
came back in and she sent logan home
she sat me down and said
ethan you have cancer
i was diagnosed with b-cell
lymphoblastic lymphoma
it was the scariest day of my life
the next morning i made my first visit
to the hospital
the place that quickly became my second
home
within 24 hours of finding out i had
cancer i started chemo treatment
i wasn't even fully awake when they
started the treatment but
my family and i knew there was no
looking back this was going to be my new
normal
my treatment protocol consisted of 12
different chemotherapy drugs
and hydrosteroids given through my port
and my chest
directly into my spine and orally
i had 28 nights in the hospital
92 clinic visits 84 port accesses with
chemo
142 blood draws 27 spinal taps
143 chemo shots 3422 chemo and steroid
pills
three surgeries six trips to the er
nine mris and ct scans four bone marrow
biopsies
four blood transfusions in july i
completed 1220 days of treatment
that's 40 months all of middle school
i miss doing all the things i love most
like playing baseball hanging out with
my friends and acting
just being a regular kid you know at the
end of the day
the worst part is that on the outside i
appear to look normal
but on the inside i'm a bit of a mess
cancer has physically taken a lot from
me
even though i've completed my chemo
treatments the side effects are still
hanging around
i still feel tired and weak i have
a very hard time sleeping my bones and
muscles ache
i have neuropathy and can't feel my
hands and feet
i currently have the resting heart rate
of
100 beats per minute because the
treatment i received
weakened the heart the average resting
heart rate for some of my age
is right around 75. chemo brain
is a real thing some days i have trouble
focusing in
my memory isn't great i am beating
cancer because of research
research and collaboration are the keys
to better treatments with fewer
long-term side effects
and ultimately a cure that's exactly
what the rally foundation does
rally has dedicated their efforts to
making my life
along with other kids lives longer and
better
they are funding the best research and
clinical trials out there
they have walked with us hand in hand
through my long journey
they were there to help us navigate the
scary stuff in the beginning
and celebrated with me when i rang that
bell
to end treatment i would also like to
introduce you to my best girl chippa
she was a gift from the rally foundation
she came home during the hardest part of
my treatment
and never leaves my side her ability to
sense what i'm feeling
is amazing sometimes she could tell
something wasn't quite right
even before i could she's the best
listener and is always willing to take a
nap with me
you know the same man's best friend it's
so
true i can't imagine my life without her
i am so excited to be a tiny part of
such a huge collaboration
i know the amazing things that the rally
foundation
and canines and kids foundation have
already accomplished
bringing together the brightest minds
in pediatric and canine care and
research
is going to change the lives of both two
and four-legged friends
and that is pretty epic
that was a really amazing
video so often we see
kids like ethan just really speak
and convey the message way beyond their
years
so that was really great and a great way
to start off this session
um we'll start off uh with
uh carl jr nicola from uh
here at penn but i wanted to remind the
audience that
please if you have any questions or
comments uh include them
um uh in the question and answer
portion below and then at the end we'll
have time to review those
and answer them uh but next we'll start
with
uh carl june which i suspect most of the
audience does not need
any introduction to uh really you know
for us
i'm here at the children's hospital
philadelphia uh to have someone like
carl
across the street uh leading the
development of
car key therapy uh at the university of
pennsylvania and everton cancer center
has been
uh obviously a boon for both pediatric
and adult cancers and
obviously that connection across the vet
school
with uh nikki has been uh ever so much
greater nikki of course leads the cancer
moonshot
um a coordinating center for the canine
cancer immunotherapy trials
and so you can really see this
interconnected space of really leading
edge development across the canine
and human elements for car t so we'll
start
um with those uh presentations
uh good afternoon it gives me a great
pleasure to present
our ongoing work uh to develop car t
cells
that are universal and this is a tag
team approach
uh we've been working with nikki mason
who will follow my presentation at the
penn vet school
my disclosures are listed here
and this work is supported by the nih
so the goal of our project
is to develop universal car t cells for
leukemia and lymphoma
initially and i will go over our
approach
which is to use
uh human genome engineering to render
the cells resistant to rejection
uh in this case uh in particular with
the dog
to overcome xenogenetic rejection
mechanisms
of human t-cells and
the translational output from this work
will be to use
dogs as a model system uh
dogs with lymphomas to test candidate
human universal car t cells
so right now car t cells are
commercially available for
leukemia and lymphoma in the united
states and they're
made from autologous cells shortly
it's anticipated that they will also be
available for
myeloma targeting the bcma
target antigen so at this point both
cd19 and soon
bcma specific car t cells will
be in the practice of medicine but they
have significant
the issue of our individual
so-called nf1 manufacturing of the cells
is difficult logistically very
intensive and then there's the vein
divine time of
how long it takes from the cells
when they're harvested from the patient
to when they're
infused and then there's another
emerging issue
is that in some patients the cells
have poor proliferation in some cases
this is due to uh
senescence or replicative uh
hayflick limits and
in this case then the use of universal
cells or third-party donor cells
would be the only
approach to
so those patients could be treated
so there are a number of differences
between when one would use
autologous cells versus universal cells
and they could either be
t cell receptor t cells or car t cells
our initial approach is to make
universal car t
cells so that they're not
mhc restricted but patient-specific t
cells uh are
[Music]
you know able to cure leukemia and
lymphoma in a higher percentage of
patients
we don't know about off-the-shelf uh
car t cells but they would have multiple
potential advantages
such as a single lot of cells could
treat multiple patients
rather than having n of one
manufacturing in real time
as with autologous cells
one could make a master cell bank
and
in addition the business model of
standard pharma models with centralized
manufacturing whereas with
patient-specific car t
cells they need to be done
beginning with at the point of care and
then
with complex logistics but there have
been reports now that
so-called donor or third-party cells
have had efficacy uh the first being
uh a re a report from great ormond
street
hospital uh published in science and
translational medicine
in 2017 and treating a few children with
infantile leukemia
so the problem with third-party cells is
is that they
um are trigger allow reactivity which is
in this case host
versus graft uh
immune reactions leading to rejection of
the cells
this doesn't happen obviously when one
uses autologous
t cells so with various genetic
engineering approaches
we believe that both
tcrt cells and car t cells could be
rendered
non-immunogenic so that they would not
be recognized by the host
immune system and there's various
approaches
to do that and that's the subject of our
project
and you know cells are rejected by
various mechanisms in in the case of
solid organ transplants
they can trigger rejection
where the host t cells become primed
through both direct and indirect image
antigen presentation
leading to organ destruction
in the case of bone marrow transplants
or hematopoietic stem cell transplants
a major issue has been uh with graft
versus host reaction which is caused by
the donor t cells killing host tissues
and this is
managed with immunosuppressive
drugs and there is a
unique issue that arises when t cells
are
transferred into uh recipients
uh and and this is uh called uh
the hybrid resistance so if one takes
for instance a parental
bone marrow into f1 generation mice
the bone marrow is rejected initially by
recipient or host natural killer cells
and this is due to
the missing self issue that
the nk cells recognize the lack of the
appropriate restricting hla
alleles and this was first described in
1964
and then has been worked out
over the years the various mechanisms of
this hybrid resistance
on this slide the mechanisms of
hybrid resistance are in paper
from canada down in the journal of
immunology
they took black six and bob c mice and
then f1
biopsy by black six mice
and infused t cells intravenously and
followed them
what they found was a striking and rapid
rejection and clearance of the cells
if they were allergenic whereas the
genetic cells survived essentially
indefinitely
uh in these mice so if
one would expect that this were t cell
mediated clearance it would not be so
rapid
and and the many uh nice
mechanisms were looked at in this study
they showed that if they depleted
natural killer cells from the mice with
an anti
acyl or gm antibody then that
prevented the the t cell rejection
and elimination they also found out that
this occurred in
t cell deficient mice as another line of
evidence that t cells were not involved
in this
elimination of the early elimination of
these infused
cells
so um what can we do then to avoid
uh this aloe recognition um
of by the host immune system uh one one
approach is to
get rid of the allergenic t-cell
repertoire and it's been fed to our
uh can be allo reactive
so by elimination of the t cell receptor
this could be
prevented and the mechanisms of aloe
recognition
by host t cells are both initially the
direct pathway
in both cd4 and cd8 cells
of the host can respond to the donor t
cells
and there can also be indirect
presentation and recognition
so our approach now to make these next
generation
universal car t cells is to first
eliminate the host aloe reactivity
that where the t cells that are infused
could cause graft versus host disease
and we also want to eliminate the
recognition of t
cells by the host the so-called host
versus graft reaction
and to do this we're using triple
editing with crispr cast 9
technology to knock out beta 2
microglobulin
c2ta which in in the t
cell receptor alpha uh locus
rendering the cell cd3 mhc
class 1 and class 2 deficient our second
approach is to
render the cells resistant to nk cell
lysis by eliminating missing self and
stress cells
itself and i'll show some experiments
using
hla e sct which is single chain
trimer this these human
engineer cells and in a large animal
model
with mickey mason and dogs
with lymphomas using human t cells that
have a c19 car
and are edited as i have uh described
um in order to eliminate t cell
recognition by both the host
and the donor-infused t cells we've used
crispr cas9 we published results back
in 2016 using um
uh in this case the beta chain t cell
receptor and beta 2
microglobulin knockout rendering cells
uh
uh mhc class 1
negative as well as cd3 negative
and these cells were completely
have lost their aloe stimulatory effects
when
incubated with irradiated peripheral
blood
mononuclear cells but the problem is
when one makes cells
mhc class 1 negative they lose
their inhibition of
that prevents nk cell lysis so that if
one has
a loss of mhc class 1
they end up being killed through
activating nk receptors
that are triggered because of the
missing self um and
this is a likely consequence that we
will face with our
t cells that have cd3 and mhc class 1
approach then is to use hlae
hle is a class 1
mhc molecule in the same
region as hla a b and c hla-edo is
monomorphic
there's one there are two alleles just
different by a single amino acid and
each hla e triggers uh
nk receptors it triggers the mkg2a
which is an inhibitory receptor and it
also triggers nkg2c
as uh sorry which was expressed as a
heterodimer with cd94
so uh by uh our experimental approach
then
is to take um k562
cells which are susceptible to lysis by
nk cells
and then engineer them give gain and
function mutations by overexpressing
hlae
variants in the
k-562 cells and uh testing them with
effector
nk cells that are grown with il-2 and
il-21 and and lcls
and these nk cells are very late
expressing a a
number of nk activated
receptors and this is a very recent data
from jerry lynette's
lab where he's shown that if hlae
single chain trimer expression reduce a
variety of e to t
ratios with uh nk
cells over expressing the the k562 cells
over expression the single chain trimer
lysis is abrogated uh
and this is uh occurs with a number of
nk
donors here these are healthy donors to
grow up the nk
cells so this looks very promising as a
way to
eliminate lysis our goal then is to test
these
universal car cells that are edited with
at the track locus beta 2 microglobulin
c2ta
and with an hlae single chin trimer and
a canine trial
with nikki mason at the penn vet school
and
she'll describe progress in that area so
in summary we've shown that donor t
cells can be rendered resistant to host
t
cell elimination but that
they are susceptible in k cell
recognition
and that hlae single chain trimer
provides potent protection from uh
to from mk cell media lysis and
and we uh hope uh during this next year
to begin a clinical trial with the mason
lab of the pandex
so in summary i've shown
work from geraldine s lab avery posey at
the university of pennsylvania
and uh funded by an nihu 54 grant
i'd like to thank you for your attention
first of all i'd like to start by
thanking um ulriki
and the canines and kids research
symposium committee
for the invitation to present here today
today when we talking about our
experiences with car t-cell therapy
um in dogs with lymphoma and i'm really
going to focus on some of the challenges
that we have seen to successful car t
cell therapy
that appear to be shared between humans
and dogs
and i think that that underscores the
value
of pet dogs for spontaneous disease for
testing next generation car t
cell therapies that are designed to
overcome
these barriers so it seems
like yesterday that this paper was
published here on the left
but it was now six years ago and this
was one of the first papers
demonstrating the
follow-up of human patients treated with
a cd1941bb
car these patients had relapsed and
refractory acute lymphoblastic leukemia
and this manuscript demonstrated these
sort of
durable sustained remissions that a
number of these patients were enjoying
and since that time attention has turned
to
trying to understand the mechanisms
behind
failure of cd19 for one bb car t
cell therapy patients and you can see
that was actually addressed in a review
recent review by crystal mackel's group
in nature medicine last year where she
divided up patients
according to reasons why they failed so
you can see 40 percent here
show a sustained complete response
whereas 60
uh failed and that was associated with
10
of patients with an inability to be able
to manufacture an autologous car t cell
product
10 demonstrated primary resistance to
the cd19 car
and the remaining 40 percent relapse
either with antigen negative disease
which was 30
with a 41 bb car or 10 relapsing with
antigen positive disease
that was thought to be associated with
loss of car t
cells perhaps because of failure of
fitness of those t
cells that were used to make the product
or immunological responses
against the car so given the impressive
responses
that have been seen using cart 19
in human patients with b-cell
malignancies including b-cell
non-hodgkin's lymphoma
we felt that it would be valuable for uh
the veterinary profession to develop car
t
cell therapies that would be effective
for dogs
with b some malignancies in particular b
cell non-hodgkin's lymphoma
we also thought that because these dogs
are immunologically competent
and develop spontaneous tumors they
would
represent a valuable model
for evaluating car t cell therapies and
maybe next generation car t-cell
therapies
that could overcome some of the barriers
that were seen in the
human patients and so this slide here
just demonstrates
our ability to generate canine car t
cells these are actually going after
cd20
and show that those cells are indeed
functional so what we're showing here is
that we've developed a
cd2028 zeta car here on the left and
cd20 bb zeta car here on the right these
are fully canine
it is a murine single chain uh that
targets the canine cd20
but the interest of the signaling
domains and the leader sequences
are canine and so you can see here
there's a lentivarly transduced car
um expressing 10 percent of these t
cells express the car
and when they're co-stimulated then with
cd20 positive targets which are the
canine b-cell lymphoma cell line clbl-1
you see an enrichment of the car
increasing percentage of the car
after several rounds of stimulation and
that then is reflected
in the expansion of the car t cells and
you can see you get a log
increase after two rounds of stimulation
and we see something similar with the 41
bb zeta cars as well
and then just demonstrating here when we
look at both the cd20 targeted bb zeta
car
and 28 zeta car and we co-culture those
with irradiated
canine gl1 cells this is a canine b cell
leukemia cell line
that has been engineered to express cd20
we see nice production of interferon
gamma
whereas the parent gl1 line we do not
see
any production of interferon gamma from
the car t cells and then here you can
see evidence
of cytotoxic activity against gl 120
cells
in both the cd20 bb zeta car and the
cd2028 zeta car
so what this tells us is that we can in
fact generate functional
uh canine car t cells
so i want to um move on to
demonstrate to you some of the
comparable
failures that we have seen with dogs
with b-cell non-hodgkin's lymphoma and
this is one patient
this is a five-year-old boxer dog that
came to us with stage five
uh b-cell lymphoma and you can see when
we look at the compartments
uh both peripheral blood and lymph nodes
here at the time he was treated with rcd
with an autologous
cd20 bbzeta car you can see that there
is a predominance of cd20 positive cd79a
positive cells
in the peripheral blood he was leukemic
and in the lymph node
obviously the dog comes off chemotherapy
after car t
cells and we do see an increase
initially in the
predominance of these cells and then of
course by the time we get to day
50 you can start to see that the
percentage of cd20 positive
cells is decreasing and we that goes all
the way through today 138
when you now see a complete loss of cd20
positive cells
and we see that also reflected in the
lymph node compartment as well but what
you will
also see of course is that you have an
emergence now
of cd79a positive cd20
negative cells and so this is an
indication
that this patient has persistent disease
that now has become a target antigen
negative so when we look at that a
little bit more carefully
and actually are able to select
cd20 negative and more cd20 positive
cells in this dog
and perform a simple semi-quantitative
pcr for cd20
you can see in the negative cells here
in lane 3
not only do we have evidence of a band
891 base
pairs this is the k9 cd20
sequence but we also now see a band at
552 base pairs
and this represents a splice variant as
you can see here from sequencing
so post treatment with a cd20 targeting
car
this patient has actually spliced out
exon 4 and exon 5 which essentially
codes for the second extracellular loop
of cd20 and it contains in green here
the domain that that cd20 car targets
and this is the reason why this patient
has essentially relapsed
with a cd20 negative
tumor so
one of the ways that is being used to
overcome that type of
antigen negative relapse is to consider
dual targeting and obviously we see
this in in the human field as well where
they're looking at combining a cd19
targeting car with cd22
in our case we have a cd20 car and so we
were interested in developing
a cd19 car and we did this utilizing a
phage
display approach so this is actually
work that was done in collaboration with
don siegel's lab at penmed
the idea here is that we generate a
canine
single chain phage display library and
we do that
from leftover spleens that have been
removed from therapeutic splenectomy
from from dogs with benign splenic
conditions
the rna and cdna is taken from these
cells and then don has divide
devised a large set of primers
that will actually amplify up all the
immunoglobulin genes so those are
responsible
for both the variable heavy and variable
light chains
both lambda and kappa and we are able
then to amplify up
uh the repertoire the variable heavy and
variable like repertoire
within those b cells and we've done that
from seven different patients and put
those together
those variable heavy and variable like
chains can then be recombined
utilizing a flexible linker to generate
single chains
that then can be expressed on the
surface of m13 phage to generate a fully
canine single chain phage display
library
and that library can then be panned
against canine antigens of interest in
this case
canine cd19 and of course using phage
display the phenotype of that single
chain is linked to its genotype
so it's then very easy easy to determine
the nucleotide sequences of the variable
heavy and variable light chains
that encode for that single chain that
binds cd19
so this is just showing a following
panning of that canine single chain
phage display library
against the extracellular domain of k9
cd19 this is eliza demonstrating
that after the third and fourth round of
panning we now have polyclonal phage
that identifies or binds to cd19
and when we take that and make
monoclonal phage
from that polyclonal population we can
identify
unique single chain binders to cd19
as you see in the bottom here
we can very readily then identify the
nucleotide sequence
of those single chains and generate
canine cars that then can be tested
and so this is just an example of how
we've we've done that
here we're utilizing jerk at cells
that have a gfp reporter in them and so
the concept here is that we can
transduce these jerk at cells with our
canine cd19
cars and then we can co-culture them
with target cells that express cd19
canine cd19
and if that car is signaling we should
then see those jacket cells
expressing gfp in response to the target
and so when we utilize one of those
single chains that we have selected
in a canine cd19 car and this is the
middle row here
and co-culture those with scaffold cells
k562 cells
that have been engineered to express
cd19 you can see that
they do indeed light up following
co-culture with these cells
demonstrating that that canine cd19 car
appears to signal and does so in an
antigen-specific manner
and we can also see signaling in
response to canine b cells where of
course we don't see that
within a relevant car or with the
non-transducer cat cells
so in addition to seeing patients canine
patients relapsing with antigen negative
disease
we have also seen a persistence or
relapse with antigen positive disease
and so we believe that this is
associated with
loss of um car t cells or failure of
their persistence and this is
demonstrated in this patient here
where we've been tracking cd24 and bb
zeta car t cells uh in a dog with b-cell
non-hodgkin's lymphoma so we've been
looking both in the peripheral blood
and in one of the affected lymph nodes
and utilizing
qpcr to track those cells and you can
see initially following
some preconditioning and then infusion
of car t cell product we see a small
expansion
that then appears to be lost
and then interestingly as this patient
progressed we treated this patient at
day
50 with rescue chemotherapy and
following that we now see an expansion
of these cells we've actually seen that
in several patients
that have gone on to progress with
antigen-positive disease
treating them with rescue chemotherapy
has led to
an expansion of the car t cells that we
can identify
here within the lymph node but again
that is then lost despite ongoing
rescue chemotherapy and what we see in
this patient is uh the formation
of the canine anti-mouse antibodies so
camera rather than hammer
and we think that that is in part
associated
with the reason why these car t cells
might fail now this dog received
preconditioning with
300 milligrams per meter squared of
cyclophosphamide which is sort of a
standard dose that we give
for chop-based chemotherapy but uh
taking our lead
from um some of the work in the human
field and
certainly here by cameron turtle
demonstrating that sort of a
a more effective more lympho depleting
preconditioning regime
uh results in better car t cell
persistence and clinical response
we increased the cytoxan dose to 500
migs per meter squared in our next
couple of patients we're able to
demonstrate
that this could then lead to a failure
or
basically prevent the canine anti-mouse
antibodies
from forming so the pre-conditioning
regime certainly seems to be important
and
increasing cytoxan seems to prevent
the anti-mouse antibodies that were
forming
we have also seen more recently in
treating a dog with a cd24 and bb car t
cell
evidence again of expansion after
a 500 migs per meter squared cytoxan
preconditioning
and that's demonstrated here so this
time we're looking in the peripheral
blood in the blue and in the red is the
lymph node
and in this patient pretty much
immediately after we administer
those car t cells we see expansion of
the car t
cells in the peripheral blood and
interestingly this correlates very
nicely
with an increase or spike in body
temperature so you can see up here
this dog's temperature went to just shy
of 106 degrees which is
is quite warm but treating just with
intravenous fluids and some supportive
care resulted
in this temperature coming down and that
again coincided
with a reduction in disappearance of car
t cells
from the peripheral circulation so i
think this perhaps
would be early evidence of perhaps an
early sort of cytokine storm
again not sustained and not serious in
this patient nevertheless
what we do see is despite this expansion
of car t cells in the peripheral blood
um the b cells in this patient continue
to increase this is after the
preconditioning they decreased
treated with car we see the increase and
we see then
loss of any control that was achieved by
that preconditioning chemotherapy and
the lymphoma comes back very quickly
within days
uh how can we make these car t cells
more effective
um in the canine system and and one way
of doing this is to try and armor these
cars
or arm these cars and we've been working
uh with ons a anzmole
from dan powell's lab at penn to try to
develop a way
of using some sort of inducible system
that could be
safe and hopefully promote the function
of these car t
cells in the hostile tumor micro
environment
which may be responsible for their
ineffectiveness as i just demonstrated
so in this situation here anzai has
actually developed
uh this inducible system so here we have
one gene that is expressed
constitutively in this case it is the
car the cd24 and bb
car and then there's a second gene that
actually is
inducible and in this first set of
experiments that's a gfp
so here we have canine t-cells that are
transduced
with this cd20 car and with this
gfp-inducible system
here's the car there's no stimulus so
it's not producing any gfp
when we stimulate these cells with a
cd20 positive clbl1 cell line
you can see now we start to get gfp
expression and this is the positive
control with a cytokine cocktail
so this tends to suggest that this
system is functional
and as we signal through the car in
response to targets
we can actually turn on that second gene
so now what anza has done has developed
a second inducible gene which
essentially is going to be canine il-12
and we have transduced canine t cells
with the cd241 bb car
we're now following signaling through
that car
we can actually get expression of canine
il-12 and this is the
the early data from those experiments
that just demonstrate
that both cars one with just a standard
car the other within
this inducible system can produce this
is actually interferon gamma
in response to stimulation with cd20
positive targets like
clbl1 and the gl120s and now
hopefully this week we will get data
back demonstrating
um that there is il-12 being produced
in these cultures finally
i just want to um sort of lead into
carl's talk demonstrating that we too
have seen issues with manufacturing
in dogs that have advanced disease and
are heavily pre-treated with
chemotherapy
so in these instances we see t-cell
populations
that have low levels of expression of
cd28 and we'll see this with aging we'll
see this with repeated antigenic
stimulation
but when we then take those t cells and
try to make a product by stimulating
them with anti-canine cd3 cd28 beads
you can see that there's there's a
complete failure
of t cell expansion in these dogs two
dogs here with advanced lymphoma and
that's in comparison
to t cells from a healthy dog which
expand
very nicely so there's a very clear
evidence
of some form of of intrinsic t cell
dysfunction
that prevents us from making a product
in these dogs
and this has been addressed to some
extent by a japanese group recently
that we're looking at expression of cd28
and some of the checkpoint molecules
on cd4 and cd8 t cells from control dogs
and dogs that had either histiocytic
sarcoma or other tumors and you can see
here although not statistically
significant
they also have recognized a reduction in
expression of c28 on cd8 positive t
cells and they've recognized an increase
in the expression of ctla4
and pd1 shown here in the cd8
compartment
on these cells from patients that
actually have
tumors including histiocytic sarcoma so
this is an
indication again that we're starting to
see some early evidence
at least phenotypically of exhaustion in
cd4 and cd8 t cells from dogs that have
spontaneous tumors
and when we look at just four patients
here so early days here
and just look at the survival of those
cells
as a function of the dose of car t cells
that these these patients receive
there's
there's not really very much correlation
there but if we look at survival as a
function
of the ex vivo population doublings per
day
that's basically the expansion of the
autologous t
cells as we're generating a car t cell
product
we can see that there's a relatively
nice correlation between if your product
is doubling nicely then you tend to
survive longer and so this is
obviously it's preliminary data but it
suggests the fitter your cells are the
more capable they are of expanding
in ex vivo to generate the product
perhaps the more likely you are to
respond
and so with that i'm just going to leave
it there
many many people to thank many
collaborations
and thank you as well to the funders of
the projects
including nih and the parker institute
well that's really a great way to
get started for this session and uh
thanks so much
to both of you we'll now turn to uh
renee chambers from uh university of
alabama birmingham
and department of neurosurgery um like
the other speakers
um she's really been a leader in the
field and i found a member of the
comparative brain tumor consortium
uh at the center for cancer research nh
um and has also been leading
uh as the principal of mexico the canine
immunotherapy trial
um really again uh demonstrating the
need for and leveraging
uh collaborations across neurosciences
and clinicians in ways that
uh really show the promise of
collaborative discovery
uh so it's to renee and and then i'll uh
hand over the uh
um uh my position back to uh dr storm
uh who will take over and i think we'll
overlap actually with renee
at hopkins when they're both there
good morning i'm renee chambers i'm
professor of neurosurgery at uab in
birmingham alabama
i'm presenting our trial design and
preliminary data from canine
an immunotherapy clinical trial in pet
dogs with gliomas
this trial is funded by the nci as a
cancer moonshot
initiative precision medicine project
and it is a collaboration between
physicians and veterinarians
at uab and regional veterinary colleges
our intent is to evaluate a combination
immunotherapy and canine glioma
and translate our findings and those of
our studies in humans
to treat both people and pets
our aims include establishing the safety
and tolerability of an oncolytic virus
alone
and then in combination with a
checkpoint inhibitor
characterizing the immune responses
using immunohistochemistry
flow cytometry and cytokine analysis
and correlating to outcomes progression
free and overall survival
we hope that sequencing studies will
give us insight into mutations conserved
across species
to serve as therapeutic targets in the
future
these are the age-adjusted incident
rates of primary malignant glioma in
humans
and in the dog you can see the
average life expectancy associated with
the median age
and other similarities between the
species
the pet dog brain tumor model is
scientifically and ethically sound
the tumors are sporadic or spontaneously
occurring the dogs have a
much shorter lifespan than humans
accelerating results in clinical trials
and numerous similarities shown here
in 2005 the canine genome project
identified 99
of the canine genome over 19 000 canine
genes
have human orthologs almost all of the
genetic alterations that influence
cancer progression in humans
have been identified in the dog finally
this model offers many advantages over
genetically engineered mouse models
including periods of latency sporadic
development
complex biology heterogeneity within the
tumor
and perhaps most importantly an intact
immune system
pre-clinical studies that advance to
human clinical trials
often fail at phase one or two we hope
that this comparative oncology effort
bridges a large translational gap
between the orthotopic
xenograft murine model in which
cells are either implanted or injected
into the equivalent organ from which the
cancer originated
and a complex immunocompetent human host
our coordinating and data analysis
center is at uab
veterinary sites where surgery and
treatment is performed include
mississippi state georgia auburn
purdue and other veterinary surgery and
specialty centers
in stage one surgery to resect the tumor
is followed by infusion of the oncolytic
virus into the tumor bed
hsv mo32 is a very immunogenic virus
it can replicate in and destroy glioma
tumor cells without affecting healthy
brain cells
it also expresses il-12 a cytokine known
to stimulate expansion
and reactivity of t helper lymphocytes
importantly based on work by pavin and
others
canine lymphocytes do respond to human
il12
in stage two the virus treatment will be
combined with a small molecule inhibitor
in doxamont
there are currently three fda approved
human
trials at uab and children's hospitals
with three different viruses
having concurrent human and canine
trials
offers real-time results and information
that can be readily translatable
the hsv mo32 is in a phase one trial
of safety and tolerability in humans
with recurrent
non-operable gliomas
at children's the hsv g207
is used in children with gliomas
and also at uab the hsv c134
with a
cmv gene and homolog of of an hsv
gene inserted to
reduce neurovirulence and still maintain
efficacy is being trialled in adults
with gliomas at uab
as far back as 1994 we were trying to
demonstrate the usefulness of oncolytic
hsb
and viruses in general in the treatment
of brain tumors in humans
trying to develop a virus with increased
selectivity for gliomas
in this case we compared the attributes
of two viruses one with a
deletion and another with a stop codon
both
blocking the gamma 34.5 gene to reduce
neural virulence
the virus we're using in this canine
trial mo32
is a non-neurovirulent and very
immunogenic
virus triggering toll-like receptors and
expressing
il-12
oral indoxamod is a small molecule
inhibitor with immunostimulatory effects
on three main cell types
it increases proliferation of the
effector cd8 positive t
cells it reprograms t regulatory cells
to cd4 positive helper t cells and it
down regulates ideal expression in the
dendritic cells
ido or endolamine 23 dioxygenase is an
enzyme that converts tryptophan to
conurenin
it's expressed by gliomas and results in
immunosuppression by inhibiting t
cells high levels of ido have been
associated with a poor prognosis
and ido blockade is expected to improve
the efficacy of immunotherapy
in stage 1 the virus is injected
into the resected tumor bed this
stimulates an immune response to the
virus
and then through cross-epitope spread to
a host of tumor antigens
that are released as the tumor cell dies
in stage 2 stage 1 treatment is followed
with 30 days of daily
oral indoximod again ido is an enzyme
that converts tryptophan to conurenin
found in high levels in high grade
gliomas
and results in immunosuppression by
inhibiting t cell differentiation
and immune evasion by the tumor
we expect endoxamide to work optimally
after the immune response is triggered
amplified and directed toward glioma
cells
as a result of blocking ibo activity we
anticipate a sustained anti-tumor
response
allowing sufficient time for the
responding cells to find
and kill most glioma cells without
immunosuppressive mechanisms
the majority of patients enrolled in the
study to date are diagnosed with
oligodendroglioma
based on histopathology approximately 46
percent are low-grade
and 54 are high-grade
22 dogs have been treated with a median
survival of 188 days
this is a significant increase from
published median survival data
for untreated cases of 60 days
we are analyzing data from stage one now
to stratify outcomes based on many
variables including
agent diagnosis tumor grade and
characteristics
such as tumor cell type ki 67
t and b cell density and the dose of
virus
etc with immunohistochemistry
we've uh identified tumor cells of
course as the majority of cells
ebba1 positive microglia or resonant
macrophages constitute the predominant
white blood cell
neutrophils are the second most abundant
subset
t and b cells are rare indicating that
the tumors are cold
that is lacking lymphocytic infiltrate
and ki 67 expression appears to
correlate with grade
we'll also analyze distribution of cells
in the adjacent normal
peritomeral and intratumoral regions
tumor grade low versus high is based on
parenchymal invasion leptomeningeal
infiltration
microvascular proliferation necrosis
and mitotic figure counts
flow cytometry
using antibodies validated for the dog
separates identifies and quantifies cell
types
this is the gating scheme created by dr
fuller our veterinary pathologist here
at uab
using antibodies size and granularity we
identified different lymphoid cells as
lymphocytes
monocytes or granulocytes t cells are
then further divided into helper
regulatory or cytotoxic one preliminary
finding correlating with the human data
is a reduction in total numbers of t
cells this is from the peripheral blood
of canine patients
suggesting that the t cells are
sequestered
this is presumed to be a significant
component of immunologic
tolerance to the tumor
the luminix bead panel uses magnetic
beads to bind
to canine cytokines and chemokines in
the peripheral blood
cytokines are hormonal messengers
produced by t
cells especially cd4 positive cells and
are responsible for most biological
effects in the immune system
they can be functionally divided into
two groups pro-inflammatory or th1
and anti-inflammatory or th2
both il-2 and interferon gamma
are indicators of cytotoxic th1
effector cell activity il4
is a th2 type cytokine
another interesting preliminary finding
is an increase in il4 expression
in the peripheral blood cd4 positive t
cells
without an increase in interferon gamma
indicating
a potential bias toward the th2 immune
response
this increase in il4 has also been
described in humans with brain tumors
and is believed to be caused by the
tumor itself the reason this is
important is that it provides an
opportunity for intervention
and more personalized treatments the
cytotoxic t
lymphocyte or ctl response may be weak
either because the cancer is
insufficiently immunogenic
or because of substantial th2 or other
component of the immune response
down regulates the generation of ctls
we plan to correlate changes in the t
cells with tumor regression or
progression
using mr and ct imaging with resist
data to determine prognostic
significance
so the questions we've generated in this
early stage of the project
are as follows we've just completed
enrollment in stage one
we continue to acquire data from those
patients as we begin enrollment in stage
two
we will follow survivals and correlate
with immune and tumor responses
with tumor sequencing to follow
questions worth investigating does il4
production by t
cells have prognostic value
is there a th2 bias in the tumor
microenvironment with tumor infiltrating
t
cells similar to what's reported in
human glioma
is this the result of an il-12 il-10
imbalance
as in humans with high grade gliomas
studies in humans have shown
patients with high grade gliomas have
decreased circulating il-12 and
increased il-10 suggesting again that
the tumors have a major systemic effect
on the immune system
and if so can this be corrected with
hsb1
il-12 therapy using mo32
in conclusion this is the first of its
kind canine
phase one clinical trial building on
high quality
pre-clinical safety and efficacy data
to delineate the safety and tolerability
of the virus
with and without a checkpoint inhibitor
in dogs with spontaneous gliomas
we hope to reveal the impact of therapy
on tumors
and the immune system and compare these
results with data from human trials
preliminary clinical results suggest
that mo32
is safe with potential morbidity and
mortality benefit
in summary this is a novel
immunotherapeutic approach
using combination immunotherapies in pet
dogs with malignant brain tumors
proving effective and safe with
increased survival times
it offers a viable alternative for pet
dogs to the current standard of care
that is surgery alone
or surgery with chemotherapy and
radiation
it provides an opportunity to identify
new targets
and therapeutic agents
it further validates the pet dog
as a model for human
glioma and further supports by
translational research to the benefit of
both species
this is the larger group of
investigators who have contributed to
this effort through the alabama
comparative oncology network
and the southeastern comparative
oncology network
and these are the active investigators
on the current trial
we have a very nice website with more
information if you or
someone you know is interested and i'm
happy to provide
updates anytime we'll keep you posted
with our results
thank you very much
all right uh thanks renee and uh thanks
for adam for
pinch hitting for me for a few minutes i
also want to remind the
the audience uh if you have a question
please put it in the ask question box
so our our next presenter is uh stephen
dao
who's a professor of immunology in the
department of
clinical sciences at colorado state
and a colleague of doug pham who's a
classmate of mine in high school and
rebecca packer who we work with
today dr dao is going to be talking us
about his work on
immunotherapy approaches to canine brain
tumors
and you know anxious to hear about what
he has to say and as we can continue to
build on this work of
comparative and translational work so
with that we'll turn over to dr dao
hello everybody uh thank you very much
for the invitation to
speak at the 2020 pause for a cure
symposium
great meeting um wonderful work being
presented
this week a series of studies
from our group looking at a new approach
to brain tumor immunotherapy and this
will build
on some of the lessons we learned from
the osteosarcoma study which
cheryl london and i will be covering
elsewhere in this symposium
overview of the rationale for why we're
doing what we're doing
and then we'll look at results from
moving to our canine brain tumor studies
so the approach we have taken is to
do two things to the tumor micro
environment
in the brain so first of all we want to
modify the immune suppressive
environment
we want to deplete the immune
suppressive population primarily of
macrophages but potentially other
myeloid cells
and then we also want to reduce the
functionality of these immune
suppressive cells
so not only block their recruitment but
also prevent them from secreting
acute suppressant molecules they're
doing that by targeting
the ccr2 pathway which is the receptor
modicide used to migrate and they're
also using
beta adrenergic blockade to reduce the
mobilization function of thyroid device
process
includes both monocytes and neutrophils
and then we're going to combine that
with a tumor vaccine
this is a vaccine that's been designed
to elicit immune responses against
cancer stem cells
which we know from prior work are very
important in the maintenance and spread
of
glioma and glioblastoma
so we're going to take the combined
approach we're going to use two drugs
to modify the tumor microenvironment
we're going to use the angiotensin
receptor blocking drug losartan
which we've evaluated extensively in the
osteosarcoma studies of dogs
we're going to combine that with
panelology beta blocker
which recent studies from elizabeth
rapasky's lab and from other
groups and show that beta blockade beta
adrenergic blockade can
significantly reduce the immune pressure
effects of myeloid cells
and have indirect effects on
angiogenesis and
t cell function and those two drugs will
be combined
in the cancer stem cell targeted vaccine
which will be generated from tumor cell
lines
from dogs that have been cultured in a
way to make them more energetic
so the this tumor spheroid lysate
protocol comes from protocols for
growing neural stem cells
and what i'm showing you in this image
is that compared to plastic adherent
cells when you take
cells tumor cells and take away their
substrate so they
no longer see how put them in serum free
medium with defined growth factors
they rapidly round up and form these
spheroid clusters
and the immune profile of these cultures
of these steroids
is much different than from standard
tissue cultures so they become
more immune stimulatory they upregulate
expression of cancer stem cell markers
which will then be incorporated into the
vaccine and the vaccine
is prepared using lysates from these
spheroid cultures and the
lysates are combined with a an effective
liposomal tlr adjuvant that
my lab has worked on a number of years
and
in male studies this spheroid culture
vaccine
becomes much more effective at
suppressing tumor growth
as seen in this image here than
conventionally plastic grown
plastic adherent supercell antigens
and then to modify the terminal micro
environment as i mentioned we're going
to use the sardine this is the
drug that our group has found and dan
regan published by speaking this last
year
it has an off target effect on ccr2
signaling
as you know it's it was it was
originally designed to be
a drug that blocks the angiotensin
receptor one
for modifying or managing hypertension
but we've repurposed this drug now for
ccr2 blockade it's
one drug out of a screen that we've
conducted
where we can consistently see ccr2
arcade at levels that can be attained
in serum or plasma by oral dosing of
losartan
and then this effect actually a property
of the it appears to be a property the
whole family of angiotensin receptor
blocking drugs so not just lysarton but
other drugs like
telemassart and omissart
and in mouse models dan's work showed
that
continuous dosing with the sardine in
mice
would eventually lead to depletion of
macrophages
in the two as shown by this f-480 dating
and also
reduced angiogenesis which
or a consequence rather depleting
macrophages you will also deplete
angiogenic factors
and then the beta blockade part of this
comes as i mentioned from
elizabeth's work but
long story short
excessive adrenergic signaling is known
to be
a an immune suppressive
in cancer and other chronic inflammatory
conditions
and if you can block that agile
signaling
with drugs or knocking out receptors you
can significantly reduce
the not only the mobilization of myeloid
cells from the bone marrow
but you can also reduce their
accumulation locally
in tissues and tumor tissues and also
reduce their functions
to suppress the secretion of immune
suppressive molecules
and in mouse tumor models blocking
a beta adrenal adrenergic signaling
with drugs such as propranolol wilson
will reduce tumor growth
and reduce the accumulation of these
myeloid populations
so we reason that it would be existent
to combine a drug that
blocks the recruitment of
bonds into tumors with a drug that also
helps block mobilization but also blocks
the functionality of the cells even if
they do make it
and then here i've summarized some of
the effects of
beta adrenergic blockade these are data
from
rodent bottles primarily which blocks
the mobilization also indirectly
improves t cell function because if you
remove the immune suppressive affects
these myeloid cells t cells start to
work again
and then you indirectly inhibit
tuberculogenesis
and in mouse models in our lab we've
shown that the combination of lasagna
propanol
appears to be uniquely effective in
stimulating the recruitment of
deceleration into disease or sub-q
models
where we're able to monitor timber
growth and
look at recruitment
particularly t cells which is the cell
we want to get
to move into first so
we we've evaluated this approach
originally in a mouse model
of the mouse glioma model
it's an induced model with the two
planet into the brain
and what i'm showing you here the a
quick um
overview of the studies these are the
treatment groups
mice mice treated with the only lasagna
parallel
bites that are vaccinated weekly at the
mice to get the combination therapy we
bought into the um response by eitis
imaging
histology at the end and we're also
going to be interested in
tumor growth in survival
so um what comes out of these studies is
that
the the combination of the
vaccine with the start number panel
gives us
better survival times we also but it's
important to also notice that those
panels by themselves are also active
compared to the vaccine groups both
groups are active
the combination appears to be additive
these studies also gave us the
confidence that this was not a
protocol that led to significant doses
and then mechanistically in terms of
what's going on in the tumor
what we see compared to what we could
control mice vaccine only we do see them
a mild instant t cells at the magenta
colored cd3 t
cells the vermin interestingly recruits
t
cells primarily in the perivascular
region just at the margin of that tumor
and then when you combine the bacteria
you see a significant increase in the
numbers of infiltrating t
cells both within the tumor tissue and
in the
peritumoral margins so it looks like
this combination really does drive a
significant t cell response so we've
taken what we learned from the mouse
studies
and we've designed a trial and dogs with
glioma glioma is a
relatively common brain tumor in
certain dogs which we'll see in a second
it's
um typically managed
um with either surgery and or radiation
therapy there's really
nothing that's particularly effective
for this tumor very similar to the
situation in humans um interestingly the
genetic
profile of this to resembles fairly
close to the profile
of pediatric glihoma
so for a variety of reasons the dog is
actually really
just a useful model for studying gliobla
in the trial that i'll describe the
biopsy was confirmed
the diagnosis was confirmed by biopsy
mri
none of the animals in our trials had
prior surgery or radiation
therapy we're going to administer
continuously high-dose losartan
propranolol orally so throughout the
study and
beyond and then the vaccine is going to
be
comprised of canine spheroid lysate
mixed with an adjuvant
they're going the animals will go
through an induction phase for 12 weeks
and then they'll stay on maintenance
so um study results today so nine dogs
have been enrolled and completed the
initial trial and it made it out to
three months um well we can and i'll
show you data here in a second but the
treatment was in general well tolerated
no adverse events
really beyond grade three both were mild
what is it one's
twos for example
uh minimal bradycardia and no
immunological side effects that we could
discern and then we've re-opened a trial
now where we're actually combining the
immunotherapy with radiation
therapy i won't smooth the results of
that
trial only three animals have been
enrolled but we've already seen
significant increases in overall
survival time with
one animal making it to three years and
then
several animals making it beyond the one
year
in the immunotherapy only trial these
are the study patients to date
you'll see lots of boxers and related
breeds represented it's a very common
tumor boxers there's
a genetic component to the tumor so
boxers
and bostons and related
brachiocephalic breeds are very highly
predisposed to this
this is a summary then of the treated
animals and the types of tumors
that we're dealing with most of our
oligodendrio
dendrogliomas a couple of astrocytomas
uh these survival times we don't really
have
good historical survival data to compare
two
but in general without treatment it's
it's
typically a matter of a few months it's
a wrap aggressing tumor
very difficult to manage and these are
the survival times that we see
coming out of the study several animals
as you
know are still alive out past the year
this is what the tumor response looks
like when it works so this
is a these are examples of two different
patients in study
this is pre-treatment mri and then
going out to uh nine months and you can
see
there's a 30 reduction in this animal's
tumor this dog had a more dramatic
regression
this is a pre-treatment then it's three
months you can see very significant
reduction
in the dimensions then again this is
only the
oral tme modifying drugs and the mexican
protocol if you look at a waterfall
plot then of lesion volumes
pre and post treatment you'll see that
there's a group
of five animals where the tumors regress
during treatment and then in this group
of four animals where the tumors
actually
progressed it did not respond so it's
still roughly a 50
rate of response which is a significant
and in dramatic improvement over what
we've been able to achieve
previously with only immunotherapy or
conventional therapy
so we're quite enthused about these
results they certainly
indicate that this immunotherapy
proto with drugs that can be repurposed
or readily
can be readily used to generate trials
without having to go through an
extensive drug approval process
the vaccine is made from cell lines so
there
it does not require tumor biopsies or
autologous cell lines these are
allogeneic cells that
can be readily grown and expanded in
culture
so the surprise of study results in what
we would conclude is that
targeting both the tumor
microenvironment and the t-cells
currently can enhance
significantly immune efficacy the
protocol was well tolerated no
significant
adverse events or it appears to be very
promising as a non-invasive non-detox
immunotherapy for managing brain cancer
and then
not surprisingly it's likely we will see
much
better result when the immunotherapy is
combined with either radiation therapy
or prior to bulking to reduce the
overall tumor mass
and that's and where we're moving next
in these studies
is looking at the combination
particularly with radiotherapy
radiation therapy so to acknowledge um
the
work the people have done the work uh
the neurology group
has been fantastic rebecca packer and
aaron rosenthal
have been the clinical neurologist
managing these patients and then
listed are also the folks in my group
who are
backing up this work in the laboratory
our work was funded by the shipley
foundation and
also by nih k dot health foundation
so i appreciate your attention and thank
you very much for
the opportunity to present our work to
you this
this afternoon thank you very much
and thanks uh stephen we'll now move on
to the uh
tag team performance uh of jeffrey bryan
and uh wayne carter uh dr brian is the
director of
pet imaging center at the university of
missouri and director of the tom and
betty scott endowed program in
veterinary oncology
today dr brian will start the lecture
off by
telling us about the immune response
against osteosarcoma
in the elias immunotherapy protocol
and i'll be followed by uh dr carter
who's ceo of t-backs biomedical
uh t-backs is the human uh correlate
of uh elias and he will talk to us about
a
human clinical trial in gbbm
dr wayne carter of tvax biomedical
to introduce the translational potential
of the elias immunotherapy approach that
has demonstrated benefit
in dogs with osteosarcoma i did present
those data earlier in the osteosarcoma
lecture so i will mention
them only briefly in this discussion
i do have a conflict of interest being a
member of the scientific advisory board
of elias animal health
the elias immunotherapy protocol is made
up of critical components that working
together appear to cause
an immune response against cancer in
patients with naturally occurring
disease
initially surgery for amputation and
collection of tumor materials
is performed these tumor materials are
used to create an autologous
adjuvanted vaccination that's
administered intradermally
and following the intradermal
administration peripheral blood
lymphocytes are collected through
apheresis
those lymphocytes are transported to
kansas city to elias animal health where
they are expanded
and then activated ex vivo into much
larger numbers and then are returned to
the hospital to be transfused into the
patient
as an active immunotherapy approach this
is followed by five injections of
low-dose interleukin-2
and the patients in our study received
no chemotherapy following that
and were simply followed for clinical
progress
each step of this important elias
immunotherapy progress has basis in
historical literature
with well-documented immunological
mechanisms
in 1984 one of the first studies of
autologous vaccination was performed in
a colon cancer
model in mice colon cancer cells or
normal mucosal cells were collected and
they were adjuvanted
with bacillus calmet guerin or bcg
and then they were the mice were
vaccinated against
their own tumor cells and you can see in
this graph to the right
that the tumor cells that were
adjuvanted resulted in a much
greater delayed type hypersensitivity
cutaneous reaction
than did the mucosal cells likely
because the tumor cells create
carry mutations that act as neo antigens
and therefore are stimulatory to the
immune system
when tumor cells and mucosal cells are
administered with no adjuvant whatsoever
there is almost no delayed type
hypersensitivity reaction at all
in the skin of these mice what's
important to understand about this
is that the same result has been shown
with almost every type of tumor that has
ever been tested
so even immunologically cold tumors can
be caused to create
a cell mediated delayed type
hypersensitivity reaction
when they are adjuvanted and
administered as vaccination
however autologous vaccination alone has
not been very effective
in treating clinical cancer
at the same time adoptive t cells were
evaluated for therapy
and in the first of its kind study
t cells that were isolated from the
spleen of mice were co-cultured
with irradiated leukemia cells to
recognize the abnormal
mutated antigens or neo antigens in
these leukemia cells
and when administered back into mice
they could cause the elimination of this
leukemia cell line from the animals
in the graph at the right you can see
that each dot
represents the death of a mouse at a
particular day
on the x-axis when mice received enough
cells five times ten to the fifth
lymphocytes the tumors were eliminated
from the mice
and none in the study died and this
study has been repeated in a number of
different types of tumors but was the
first of its kind to recognize
that tumor-specific activated t cells
could indeed clear cancer from a mouse
model
it was later discovered that these t
cells
did not have to be tumors specifically
activated that if the t
cells were exposed to the tumor
neoantigens
and then removed from draining lymph
nodes from the mice themselves
they were expanded x vivo and then
activated with staph enterotoxins
that those t cells were now active
enough to eliminate
in this case a fibrosarcoma model of
intracranial cancer in these mice
and what you can see in these graphs is
that the
cells that were activated with either
staph and neurotoxin a
staphrotoxin c or even staph enerotoxin
e
were more likely to be able to cause
prolonged survival in the mice
then those activated by other means are
not activated at all
so this non-specific activation of
previously educated
anti-tumor t cells could also result in
an anti-tumor reaction in these mice
this was then further extended to
identify that
autologous vaccination into the animal
themselves that could activate the t
cells and then the t cells could be
removed and activated non-specifically
that those could also eliminate even
existing metastatic disease in this case
a metastatic model of melanoma
showed that mice that were in vaccinated
with
at least three times ten to the seventh
irradiated tumor cells
admix with c parvum as the adjuvant for
the vaccine
and then given adoptive immunotherapy
could eliminate
all of the metastatic lesions already
present in the lungs showing that even
advanced disease
could be managed by immunotherapy
particularly in the setting of
autologous vaccination
and activated t cells and in each of
these cases the immune mechanisms were
well described and were
recapitulated in many studies following
them
each of these components of previously
well validated
immunotherapy approaches in mouse models
was then extended through elias
immunotherapy into the naturally
occurring disease of osteosarcoma
in the dog species each of these dogs
received a vaccination prepared from
their own tumor cells and adjuvanted
they then underwent apheresis to remove
those educated t
cells from their blood which were
expanded and activated ex vivo
and then they were transfused back into
the patients who then received low-dose
interleukin-2 therapy following
and then were followed simply for
clinical outcome none of them received
chemotherapy
and what we learned from this study is
these dogs had an extended disease free
interval
that in some cases even when they
relaxed resulted in further survival
more than is typical for dogs who
received chemotherapy alone
we also saw an extended survival average
of 415 days median
with five dogs alive out of 14 enrolled
in the study at the end of a two-year
period
following this infusion so each of these
previous
immunotherapy tenets was recapitulated
in a clinical response in these dogs
with osteosarcoma
and because it has previously been shown
that nearly
any tumor cell type can create a
vaccination that can cause a t
cell response the results of this study
are potentially generalizable
into other diseases and dogs as well as
other diseases in humans
and it's the strength of these data that
is allowing
this to to carry forward into a clinical
trial in humans in brain cancer
that dr wayne carter will now discuss
thank you jeff jeff and i are our tag
team in this presentation uh so i also
would like to thank
the organizers and enrique for the
invitation to present today
i'm dr wayne carter the ceo of tvx
biomedical which is the human health
counterpart to elias animal health
obviously you've already heard of elias
animal health and the efficacy they have
in osteosarcoma
and for disclosure purposes tvx also
owns about 30
of elias animal health so just to remind
us again of the technology
the surgery removes the primary tumor we
isolate about 50 million cells from that
tumor in our lab
we then irradiate the cells so they're
no longer capable of growth or
replication
combining with gm csf as an adjuvant a
little bit different than on the
than in the dog and then after the
second vaccination we do uh
leukopheresis
uh to collect the the mononuclear white
blood cells
then take those t cells outside of the
body activate them
expand them and then infuse back about
50 billion
activated effector t cells back into the
patient
and then we follow that up with il2
injections to continue the in
vivo activation and expansion of those
those t cells
so this is an autologous cancer vaccine
enhanced adoptive t cell therapy our
therapy actually consists of two
different manufactured products the
vaccine
and the t cells we have efficacy in
multiple cancers we really believe this
is a platform technology but today i'm
only going to talk about
the brain cancer results we have very
few side effects with the therapy
um there are you get some mild swelling
associated with the the vaccination site
which is what we want because we want
you to have a robust immune response to
the vaccine
and then about a third of the patients
will have a low-grade fever and a little
malaise for
about 24 to 4 48 hours when they receive
their t cells back
so it's a much different safety profile
than most of the
of the treatments for cancer which are
on the market today
and we've just recently received fda
fast track designation for
our phase 2b study in gbm
so um i'm going to talk about one other
preclinical
study to sort of take us into the the
brain cancer
realm and so this is work that dr gary
wood
did the founder of tvax in our cso about
30 years ago
this is in a very aggressive rat
high grade glioma model it's an rt2
glioma
and the control rats uh
die off very quickly with this model uh
importantly
as you can see here um all of the rats
that were treated with the adoptive
t-cell therapy
survived and uh this was really
uh gary wood's aha moment and really
recognizing that this therapy was was
really something special
and that's when he really started and
embarked on
on a very long journey for tvx
this is um a kaplan-meier curve which
shows
historic controls for high grade gliomas
and as you can see unfortunately they
their
survival drops off very quickly this
study in particular
with the immunotherapy was done in human
recurrent
high grade gliomas and so these patients
already had had multiple
surgeries and chemo radiation therapy
etc
and so they had suppressed immune
responses they were really
most of them at the end of their life
and yet as you can see
we were able to extend the survival in
really all of those patients by over 2x
and importantly at the bottom of this
you can see that we were able to
significantly increase the duration of
the survival in about 20 percent of the
patients
and again it's important to appreciate
that this occurred
uh obviously in these patients that had
recurrent
high grade gliomas after they had
received immunosuppressive
chemo radiation therapy and so when
you're depending on the immune system to
to work you know properly it's amazing
honestly that we were able to get this
kind of
of responsiveness from patients that
were had such
suppressed immune responses this is one
patient in particular
that had a complete response to the
therapy
this patient as you can see has a very
large
glioma which is present at baseline
you can see it in these three slices 20
uh two months after the completion of
the immunotherapy you can see that tumor
has decreased significantly in size
and then eight months later you can see
it's almost completely gone
ultimately this was a complete responder
and they survived over five years and
then were lost to follow up
i know there's a lot of interest in
pediatrics uh with this group and so
we have actually treated about six
different pediatric patients
uh this is one that had again a gbm of
glioblastoma
and as you can see here a very large
tumor present in this child
this is before the immunotherapy and
then three months after the
immunotherapy you can again see that
tumor has decreased significantly in
size
moving forward we're going to be
focusing on
adult gbm we have fast track designation
for a gbm in adults and we also have
orphan disease indication granted by the
fda
there is no effective treatment for a
specific
subset of gbms which are the mgmt
negative gbms those are the ones that do
not respond to
temozolomide and those are the ones
which we will be focusing on in the
study
it'll basically be a one-to-one
randomization receiving standard of care
which is the temozolomide radiation
versus the standard of care plus our
immunotherapy
we have also considered a pediatric arm
to this
and certainly we would consider it if we
receive adequate funding for that that
pediatric
arm to the study this is what the study
will look like
um again surgery is performed enrollment
after the surgery
uh because we have to confirm that it's
a gbm and an mgmt negative they then
receive their first vaccination within
about a week
we continue to inject gmcsf into the
vaccination site
on three subsequent days to continue
that dendritic cell activation at the
vaccination site
they receive then the second vaccination
and also the gmcsf
and then we will um collect the white
blood cells again
through a leukophoresis the radiation
tempozolomide
is administered uh in a six-week time
point after the leucophoresis
and so all of this priming of the t
cells occurs
before there's significant
immunosuppression from the radiation of
temozolomide
and then we will administer the
activated effector t
cells back to the patient after the
radiation templazolamide again
is done so that we don't interfere with
the function of those t cells
and then the il-2 is given to continue
that in vivo expansion
so there are three key differences of
this study in comparison to studies that
we've done in the past
so these immune cells are going to be
generated from patients that have
healthy immune systems
as was done with the canine osteosarcoma
study
it's also important to appreciate that
these patients are going to have minimal
residual disease
which is going to be brought about by a
combination of the surgery
and the um and the chemotherapy
the third thing is that the cancer
neoantigen specific effector t cells
will be delivered by adopted transfer
after the patients have received the
chemotherapy which will bring about a
more
immunostimulatory environment for those
t cells to hopefully have a more
favorable environment
than the more typical and you know
suppressive environment which exists
inside a tumor our challenges for tvacs
have been funding
funding and funding for the past decade
we simply have not been able to put
adequate funding together to complete
our human uh clinical trials and so
accordingly in around 2014 we were
actually able to put enough money
together
to start an animal health company in the
kansas city area and so elias animal
health was started
you now know the results of elias animal
health they've obviously had a
successful osteosarcoma study
and are moving forward with a
registration study those translational
results have also
obviously given us movement and impact
to hopefully move forward again with a
with a human clinical study
in that interim period of time cartes
have now been been approved and so
um adoptive t-cell therapies are now
more real to pharmaceutical companies to
payers
tills the tumor infiltrating lymphocytes
another adoptive t-cell therapy are now
also moving forward
and we've now also received fast track
designation so hopefully we are
are getting close to to being past the
hump
and uh and really then starting our our
hopefully our registration study
so thank you again for the invitation
and i look forward to any questions
great well uh so thanks uh jeff and
wayne will now uh
finish with uh elias sar uh
he's an assistant professor of
neurosurgery and pediatrics and pi of
the rna engineering laboratory
in the uh preston wells junior center
for brain tumor and immunotherapy
program
he's also a member and active
participant in the
clinical trial network pinoc and today
he's going to talk to us about
the cancer ecosystem and ways to develop
pediatric cancer vaccines so we'll let
elias
take it away
good afternoon everyone i want to thank
the organizers for inviting me to speak
here today
specifically k9 and kids and pause for a
cure
i'm going to be talking about
accelerating translation of pediatric
cancer vaccines
through comparative oncology
so in order to develop new therapies
against cancer
we need a better understanding of what
cancer is
and cancer is not just cells dividing
indiscriminately cancer is an ecosystem
and in this ecosystem you have
cancer cells you have blood vessels
that are creating a network within these
cancer cells
and you have other cell populations in
the tumor micro environment
and these populations involve immune
cells
like macrophages and k cells
and t cells but the immune system
in the cancer ecosystem tends to
recognize
cancer as a friend and not a foe
and this regulation within the tumor
micro environment is not just confined
to the cancer
but it's also can it's also
affecting the systemic circulation
and so there is significant
immunosuppression
within the systemic circulation there is
immunoregulatory mechanisms that affect
compartments like the bone marrow the
liver the lymph nodes the spleen
so cancer is not just a local disease
but it's a systemic disease
associated with profound systemic
immunosuppression
in order to overcome this we've
developed a new
platform technology that can activate
the immune system
both systemically and in the tumor
microenvironment
and to do this we've developed
nanoparticles nanoparticles
that can take up the genetic information
of a patient's individual tumor and when
injected into the bloodstream
these nanoparticles can elicit an immune
response
within the periphery in these organs
ends within the tumor microenvironment
and by making cancer look like a
dangerous virus
we get activation in all of these areas
so to do this we are making personalized
vaccines and from as little as 100 to
500
biopsy cancer cells we can extract
total rna from that rna we can make a
cdna library and from that cdna library
we can amplify
copious amounts of messenger rna that's
personalized to that individual cancer
we then load the rna material into
a custom lipid nanoparticle these lipid
nanoparticles are biocompatible
and when they take up the rna
by electrostatic interactions we form
these multi-lamellar complexes
these multi-lamellar complexes can then
be injected right into the bloodstream
through intravenous administration
and we found that when we inject these
into the systemic circulation we get
activation
of all of these immune cells in the bone
marrow liver
lymph node spleen we get activation of
immune cells in the tumor
microenvironment
and within the tumor we see a lot of
immunoregulatory mechanisms turning into
activated mechanisms
and lastly we see traditional vaccine
effects
dendritic cells or dc's or master cells
of the immune system
they're responsible for educating t
cells
and those t cells are responsible for
trafficking to the tumor
and killing the thing that they've been
educated against
so from an rna loaded nano liposome
we can see significant systemic and
intratumoral reprogramming
and this reprogramming unlocks the
vaccine effects
that we're inducing
there are existing mrna vaccine designs
uh certainly madurana curvac and bio and
tech
are pharmaceutical companies that are
prioritizing development of
mrna mrna is not inherently stable on
its own
although it can be stabilized often a
liposome
is used a lipid nanoparticle is used to
protect
that material that mrna from degradation
and that r and that rna can be confined
in an rna lipoplex in the center
of that nanoparticle or it can be
confined to the outside
of that lipid nanoparticle in the form
of an anionic rna lipoplex
what we're doing is we're layering rna
in a different manner we're layering rna
into these lipid nanoparticles using
electrostatic
alterations of positive and negative
charge
we have a positive liposome and we layer
negatively charged rna
followed by another positively charged
liposome and then followed by another
layer of rna and so on and so forth and
these multilamellar complexes we're
generating
actually condense into teeny tiny
particles that are 100 nanometers in
size
because of the electrostatic
interactions between the positive and
negative charge and so in effect these
are like nano onions
and we believe these are much more
immunogenic than other
rna loaded liposomes or rna-loaded
nanoparticles
because these nano onions have much more
rna inside of them and rna can be
quite immunogenic through stimulation
of pathogen recognition receptors like
toll-like receptors
and we've tested these head to head when
we compare multi-lamellar rna
nanoparticles
to anionic lipoplexes or
rna lipoplexes we see significantly
increased percentages of activated
dendritic cells
with our rna nanoparticle formulation
we also see increases in
antigen-specific t
cells and we see significantly greater
anti-tumor efficacy and so on the far
right is a murine model
of cancer this is a metastatic
lung tumor model and we see that rna
nanoparticles
elicit improvement in median and overall
survival benefits relative
to other formulations
we also see anti-tumor efficacy in
several other models we see anti-tumor
efficacy in head and neck cancer models
melanoma models sarcoma models
and other metastatic lung tumor models
and for pediatrics we've also
investigated these in the context of
urine models for osteosarcoma
osteosarcoma
is the most common malignant bone tumor
in children
and certainly these vaccines given once
weekly
times three elicited significant
improvement
in survival benefit we see that
within these tumors we're activating the
dendritic cells these master cells of
the immune system
and although not shown here we see these
dendritic cells activated
in every organ we assess we see these
activated
in lungs and liver and bone marrow
spleen and lymph nodes
within the tumor we also see an increase
in central memory t
cells and we and when we take t cells
from
mice that were vaccinated with rna
nanoparticles and we re-stimulate them
with
the osteosarcoma cells we can see a
memory recall response
through the production of gamma
interferon
we also see activation of innate
gene signatures within the tumor
microenvironment
after an rna nanoparticle vaccine in as
little as 24 hours if we were to harvest
a tumor after a single
a singular vaccine we see
increases in nh signatures for affector
dendritic cells
and interferon regulatory factors and
interferon response genes
so we're essentially shifting these
regulatory environments
from a tolerant state to an activated
state
in as little as one vaccine
when we funnel down mechanistically into
what is eliciting these responses
we see increases in type 1 interferons
type 1 interferons are part of the
canonic antiviral signature
and this signature is important
for fighting and containing a viral
spread interferon alpha though is
also important for inducing a adaptive
response
and when we when we block interferon
alpha
using monoclonal antibodies we can
actually completely abrogate the
anti-tumor efficacy scene with this
vaccine
and when we deplete plasmacytoid
dendritic cells
we can significantly significantly
attenuate this interferon signature
so mechanistically these rna
nanoparticles work through
type 1 interferons that are being
released from plasmacytoid dendritic
cells
so based on these data we have
translated these findings into
canine studies we've initiated a canine
study
for pet jobs with terminal gliomas
and we've initiated a canine study
in pet dogs with osteosarcoma
these these studies and pets are so
important
because we can now evaluate the safety
of this vaccine and a much more relevant
model for cancer these are spontaneous
tumors
we do not inject these dogs with cancers
these are spontaneous tumors in these
animals
that will claim their lives and these
patients are eligible through the
owner's consent
for these types of therapies which will
allow us not only to
learn more about the safety but also to
learn about what dose works best
and what are the blood markers that show
response
in these animals and then we can use
this information
for a human clinical trial not only to
get approval through the food and drug
administration
but also to better design a human trial
and so in our first patients with
terminal gliomas
we were able to confirm some of the
biologic correlates
that we have found in our mouse models
namely we see increases in interferon
alpha
these type one interferons that are so
important for
vaccine response to this rna and a
particle vaccine
we see increases in interferon alpha in
as little as two hours
in these canines and this was an
earlier signature than we when we saw
this in mice and mice we saw this around
six hours so
knowing that this is increased in dogs
in as little as two hours
will help us uh in our human trial
in terms of knowing when to look these
patients do develop
low-grade fevers within a few hours of
this vaccine
which we believe is is a signal that we
are
inducing good inflammation and
initiating response
against the tumor antigens that we are
presenting using these rna nanoparticles
these patients with terminal gliomas
don't
get any other therapy other than rna
nanoparticles
they get a vac they get a biopsy that
allows us to manufacture
personalized uh personalized vaccines
but they're not treated with any other
therapy and
these tumors are not resected outside of
a singular biopsy
we also see activation of dendritic
cells
and t cells in these canines
we see this activation in as little as a
few hours
this is very very important because
one of the reasons vaccines don't work
in the context of cancer is they take a
long time to boost
to illicit response so to see activation
of dendritic cells and t
cells in as little as a few hours is a
very good sign
for this platform we also see
interestingly enough within a few hours
market decreases in peripheral blood
mononuclear cells both monocytes
and lymphocytes and we believe that
this is representative of these cells
activating and marginating two lymphoid
organs
for the purposes of anagen education of
t cells
but most importantly is the response and
in our canines with terminal gliomas we
have seen
smaller tumors after three vaccines
given one week
apart and interestingly in some of these
patients that develop smaller tumors
there's actually increased swelling and
these scans are read a pseudo
progression
and we attribute this to actually an
inflammatory response within the tumor
that's causing that increased swelling
we've treated five canines with terminal
gliomas thus far
and within these patients we've seen
again this is a small cohort of patients
but
we have certainly seen improvement
in what the median and mean survival
outcomes are for this disease
in terms of our osteosarcoma trial and
canines we've treated three dogs so far
and we have one
uh one long-term survivor
based on this data collectively we were
able to submit
an investigational new drug application
to the fda
and this has since been approved and
we are now in the process of initiating
a human clinical trial
and that trial is going to be in
patients adults and children with
malignant brain tumors
and is expected to start in the next
couple of months
and this trial really is only possible
through
uh the large animal work that we have
done
in pet dogs and while this work has
allowed
us to reach human clinical trial
application
it's also created a pipeline where we
can do bench
to bedside research at bedside to bench
research
using a large animal a model as an
inflection point
in terms of allowing us to know whether
it's safe to move forward into human
clinical trials and whether things are
working
so in summary comparative oncology is an
accelerant in translating discovery
driven efforts and it has allowed
for large animal studies in
physiologically relevant systems
uh it has allowed us to identify human
equivalent dose necessary for our
clinical trials
validation of biomarkers and the
opportunity to help both of our pets
and our children that suffer with these
terrible diseases i thank you for your
attention and happy to take
questions
all right i guess we'll open it up to
any questions
i do see down in the new question box
if human glioma patients tend to be less
responsive to treatment with increasing
age
those in their 30s do much better than
those in their 60s
is there a similar situation in canines
i can um i can speak to that we've not
seen that to date but we're still
stratifying outcomes
uh based on things such as age so we may
see that
to date we have not with our 22 dogs
we've not seen a trend favoring older
younger dogs and survivals
then i think renee and your in your data
look like a
large number of the the high grade
gliomas or oligodendrogliomas
is is that are those are they one
p19q deletion oligos i mean
i can't tell you that yet um we we've
looked at the grade the
immunohistochemistry only
and so we but we will tell you as soon
as we get some sequencing
just because as you know i mean oligos
are quite rare but it
looks like in the canines at least i
guess
the histologic diagnosis uh is quite
high so i was just curious if
if you're finding the same same mutation
that we are
in the human oligos yeah we're really
looking forward to the genomic work and
that's we're sort of saving that for the
end we've archived tumor
um and we'll do all the genomics at once
we've got uh
nano string rna-seq and then whole exome
plan so we'll see
um i actually had a question again for
any of the vets when
they talk about these the
brachiocephalic dogs like the boxers
uh you know in humans uh april syndrome
or cruisons uh are often brachycephalic
you know it's a fg or hfgfr receptor
but i mean i i can't remember ever
treating
an aperts or crouzon patients
uh with a brain tumor yet it seems like
against the same
i think the same mutation in in like
pugs
and bulldogs that we see in the crouzons
and april's
kids i was just curious dude
is there any other known mutation along
with the fgf2 receptor
i don't know
it's just breaking right it's the same
mutation and we're seeing and you it's
all these
these dogs with that that the
brachiocephalic are getting these these
uh tumors but
we just in our cranial facial clinic we
never and we follow these kids
well into young adulthood and we just
never see it
it's true and and i will point out that
that boxers are
predisposed to a lot of different tumors
so i'm going to guess that there is
another driver in boxers that that makes
this multifactorial
the other thing is that pugs are a
different lineage that don't come from
the english bulldogs like the boxers and
the boston's do
pugs have are a are a similar mutation
separate origin and so they don't get
some of the
tumors you know particularly um the
heart based tumors
at the aortic um you know the aortic
body tumors that we see in the
boston's and the boxers so i i it'll be
interesting to look at the difference in
genomics between
things that happen in pugs and the other
brachyphalics because that might be en
enlightening as to what we're looking
for looking for differences there
yeah we're always looking like you said
for those other
predispositions and we can see a patient
with lee framini who's
seven and has a gbm and her sister has
the exact mutation who's in college and
doesn't have
a single tumor right so there's
obviously some other predisposition
going on and probably epigenetic factors
as well
sure and then
wayne with the with those the long-term
survivors and that tvx
kaplan-meier curve do you know any of
those subtypes were they like idh1
mutants or was there anything that you
knew when you looked at those long-term
survivors that you were able to
to tell if there was a subtype or what
mutation maybe
yeah there was there's limited some
typing done no we really can't
draw any correlations there at all um
certainly
you know going forward is something we
plan to look at more carefully but
but uh but not with the past studies
certainly exciting
it is and uh you know it as
uh you know as a i so i'm obviously a
veterinarian and and so i
appreciate the osteosarcoma data very
well and and i also appreciate i think
the the translational aspect very well
and uh i truly truly believe that it's a
you know it's a platform technology that
can work
potentially against any cancer and you
know i must
reflect as i you know have listened to
many of the courageous warriors
and their presentations you know over
the past two days
um and and i hear about the the terrible
uh
side effects that they have uh you know
had to endure and you know i think
that's one of the great things about
you know an adoptive uh cell therapy
like ours
is there there are just so few side
effects associated with it
and you know i do hope that at some
point it be treatments like that become
more of the mainstay as opposed to
starting with such aggressive
chemotherapy and then the patients
dealing with all those side effects
i see there's a question from brian from
hopkins maybe it was discussed
earlier in a different session and i
missed it but if not what is the status
of checkpoint inhibitor development for
canines
i think they will be needed to optimize
t-cell-inducing therapies
i don't know for nae you want to take
that one
yeah it's interesting we've talked to
several companies about trying
like pembro or different drugs the
indoximod is just a small molecule
inhibitor
i i don't i don't know but i hope that
the results of this trial will lead to
uh sort of easier access the willingness
of these companies to provide drugs you
know
this is no surprise to anyone if you
have a trial and you
you um solicit a company to provide a
drug the last thing they want to see is
a bad outcome
from their drug that they're trying to
market so it's a little bit of a um
you know you need some pilot evidence to
get them to participate and you can't
get pilot evidence without them
participating
so hopefully with some results of these
combination immunotherapies
these companies that are trying to get
drugs you know sort of out there
uh will be more willing to provide the
checkpoint inhibitors
we are just now starting stage two so we
haven't actually administered the
checkpoint yet
maybe jay one thing that's worthwhile um
to mention um you know it's the
um sort of going live of the race act
um this year so the race act is a
congressional act
really launched after an initiative by
foundations
and patients and families where now
from school companies who are developing
compounds
or drugs for adult therapies are
required
to simultaneously
assess those therapies in a pediatric
oncological setting if the relevant
target
um is available there so you know it's
one of the things that we hope at least
on the pediatric side
can provide for a common um
approach but this could be you know
really a great
opportunity to intersect in the canine
modeling
space as a way to help prioritize and
define
such approaches across the pediatric and
adult space i'm not sure if any of you
have
thought about this or or evaluated how
canines can be a conduit for support and
a
farmer-based engagement and their need
to potentially
think across the pediatric adult context
it certainly seems you know like a
reasonable thing the challenge we have
is sometimes the pharmacology of drugs
is different in dogs than it is in
people and
uh cheryl london were here she would
point out a good example of that is
synitinit that results in some unstable
metabolites
in in the dog but tosarinib
which is a very close drug is very
stable and
and works well in dogs and so assuming
that we have good
pharmacologic data and good pk
understanding
then i do think that the dog offers an
opportunity when the similar mutations
are present
and certainly a number of those
mutations have been identified
i don't see any more questions here in
the question box
a little over time but if anyone has any
pressing questions we're happy to
address them
uh otherwise i find this uh
relationship in uh between the canines
and
certainly children and all brain tumors
unbelievably exciting
and for me it's always great to
hear what my veterinarian colleagues
are doing and uh and we're
we have a project going with rebecca
packer that's going to be starting soon
so
uh you know it's neat to continue to
work together and and then hopefully uh
continue to integrate especially uh what
we can bring is the
the large whole genome sequencing
uh to then integra continue to integrate
that
uh as you all get more uh more data
subtypes and genomic
sequencing for the k-9 so i think it's a
great
great partnership and i always enjoy
this conference and seeing everybody and
catching up with
renee that i didn't see in years until
last year's conference and
nicki's like right across the street and
didn't even know all the neat stuff she
was doing so uh
i said it's great for us and uh you know
adam and i are excited to keep
uh keep moving forward so thanks to all
the presenters uh
great work and uh look forward to
staying in touch and keeping up again at
the next conference so thanks
take care thanks jay